let's talk about super mice I'm not
talking about Mighty Mouse we're talking
about super mice they are on their way
that's right scientists at the
University of Rochester in New York have
created a super Mouse and we've got some
info for you
researchers found that the super Mouse
is much smarter than traditional mice
basically they implanted human brain
cells in a normal Mouse that's what
happened here in one test that measures
the ability to remember a sound
associated with a mild electric shock
the humanized mice froze for four times
as long as other mice when they heard
the sound suggesting that their memory
was about four times better all right
super mice I think this is sort of the
plot of spider-man 2 wasn't the lizard
wasn't that what he was trying to do to
get the extra arm kind of thing like
we've heard about this kind of stuff
island of dr. Moreau there's plenty of
movies on this kind of genetic splicing
animal human stuff this seems pretty
cool this seems pretty cool to me like
that we can maybe do something here - I
don't make animals smarter or what are
we thinking I mean I think it's pretty
cool because dumber and we're all going
to look Charles you've known about Pinky
and the brain for a long time I just
think it's cool because we could use the
research done on these mice to help
people you know who have different
diseases that like myelin sheath
degradation and stuff like we can help
build that back up with only goat under
cites and stuff that they're using from
the glial cells so you know so I mean
stuff like that doesn't know he doesn't
know what you just said for the regular
person - so they have glial cells and
they could turn into either astrocytes
or oligodendrocytes the astrocytes are
used more for like repair and different
things like that and neurotransmission
and the le goat under cites are used to
make myelin which can also you know like
if you have my lunch ether gradation and
different diseases like multiple
sclerosis you know you could use it to
repair things like that so I mean
whenever you do research like this you
could take the information and use it to
help people but I'm not really worried
about a super mutant mouse taking over
you so I'm just gonna that's a little
superhero a little bit because then we'd
have to have someone like maybe a
teenager from Queens would have to be
hit by a radioactive spider to then deal
with the it's a lot I'm just putting
this up a legitimate science right I'm
gonna back up a little bit and say so
okay what's actually happening here is
that these researchers decided to take
human cells and like you said inject
them into Mouse brains and what they
found was [ __ ] amazing which was that
the mouse brains took the cells not only
integrated them into the architecture of
the brain but actually proliferated them
so over time we've got two types of
cells in our brain two gross types of
cells that's a gross a lot that's the
word of the day we have neurons which
are kind of like the the functional
units in the brain and they're the ones
that do the chemical and electrical
transmission and then we have glial
cells which outnumber neurons like ten
to one and glial cells are support cells
they do lots of things like you said
they provide scaffolding and
architecture they myelinate the neurons
which is put a sheath around them so
that transmission happens faster
lots of things microglia clean up there
a little bit of an immune response so
what they found is that when they
injected the human cells into the mouse
brains some mice maintain their own
neurons their own functional units but
they they they took on the human glia
and over time they lost their own glia
and they actually became more populated
with the human glia so now there's this
crazy hybridized brain that's
functioning on its own it took it in and
it's able to function on its own that in
and of itself is amazing it has
absolutely nothing to do with these very
very early findings of memory
improvement or like super amount that's
all it's on media [ __ ] I say don't
give that a moment of thought what
they've provided here is a mouse model
to be able to study human diseases of
the glial system because they can do it
in vitro in a way that would never be
ethical in a human brain you can't go in
and tinker with a human brain and then
see what happens to the patient so now
they can do things in a mouse model that
they could only do in vitro before
meaning in a petri dish now they can
actually do it in the mouse and see what
happens this is a wait-and-see moment if
memory is improved
we've got improvement of these kinds of
disorders of myelin sheaths and things
like that but it could open up a whole
new realm of research that's really
exciting yeah I suspect I know the
answer on this but where do you guys
stand on testing on animals in general
now I get that of course this is
different testing something like this is
certainly different than testing for
lipstick right and I was just gonna say
it depends on what it's for I mean
obviously if we are looking to make you
know scientific advancements sometimes
this type of thing is necessary if we're
gonna help you know cure human diseases
then you know yeah go for it but if
we're just dropping you know shampoo
into eyes of rabbits you know just don't
put the stuff in your eyes you know how
hard is that so I mean like I am largely
against animal testing for cosmetics you
know that are to that degree we're just
literally dropping acid and eyes of
animals but stuff like this you know is
kind of enough they ever find that the
acid in the eye doesn't hurt you know
wow we didn't expect this outcome it
hurts yeah and this is something that I
often times am really a little bit upset
about when you look at media approaches
and activist approaches to animal
research is that they try to they try to
see equivalency between scientific
research and like you said cosmetic
research that's some [ __ ] that stuff
that happens with no IRB approval that
stuff that happens in private medical
Institute or private corporate
institutions you know pet food companies
cosmetic companies things like that but
when we talk about legitimate science
government-funded science science that's
happening in public and private
universities there are insane protocols
that have to be covered you can't do
research on animals if there are certain
ethical ramifications it has to be
minimally invasive to the animal to get
the desired outcome it has to be
minimally painful to the animal you're
always trying to improve the safety and
the health of the animal I I definitely
see cut offs with animal research I have
a hard time with the idea of doing
animal research on dolphins elephants
and great apes yeah but but much below
that I'm a huge advocate of animal
research and but I'm an advocate of
talking about animal research in a
responsible way and I think a lot of
times what happens is that the activists
focus on third-rail things that aren't
even the real conversation legitimate
animal research is absolutely necessary
for a functioning society and for
improved medical care and anybody who
says that they're against animal
research should never take another pill
and their [ __ ] lips and they should
never get surgery because none of that
could exist without animal research
sorry sorry to tell you that's just the
way it is I have one great resource for
this look up speaking of research it's
an amazing organization that advocates
for animal research and disseminates
appropriate information to the public
that is not you know valence twit kind
of hysteria and and media fear-mongering
well there you go all right so look up
speaking for research